- Hi, I'm Simone De La Rue.
Creator of Body By Simone.
Here are five simple exercises
that are gonna give you
a full body workout.
Let's start off first with cardio.
We're gonna do a jump squat.
This is working our largest
muscle groups in our body.
So that's working our quads,
our hamstrings, and our glutes.
And it's gonna fire up our
heart rate so that we're really
gonna get in our cardio fix
for a nice jump squat, so you start down,
you jump up in the air, and lower down.
Again, jump up and lower down.
Jump up and lower down.
And squeeze.
Yes, you're gonna do
three sets of 10 of those.
Heart rate will be up.
That is your cardio.
The next exercise, shoulder press.
We're working our deltoid and our pecs.
I'm using a resistance band, the CLX band.
You can use hand weights,
or you can use cans or bottles of water.
Come back down again into
your squat, up to goal post.
Reaching up and down.
And up and down.
Upper body workout.
Deltoid, chest.
Pull in those abs, keep
those shoulders down.
If you have hand weights, pushing them up.
And up.
Excellent.
We're also gonna do three
sets between 10 and 12 reps.
Third exercise is the plank.
So we're gonna come back
to our static plank.
Elbows over top of wrists, I should say.
Kick back, tuck that little booty under.
Everything's engaged, and hold.
I'm gonna lower my back
knee down and lift it up.
My front knee down, and lift it up.
And both knees down, and up.
And down again.
Back knee.
Nothing's moving off my back.
You can have a tray of
cookies or a tray of champagne
resting on there and they will not spill.
And what's really working
into your lower abs.
And down.
Let's do one more time, perfectly still.
Lower abs, lower abs.
Both and both.
And up.
And rest.
Good.
Three sets of 10 to 12 reps of those.
You're especially gonna
feel that in your lower abs.
Next exercise, booty, yes.
We want a nice shapely booty.
I'm gonna use the resistance band again.
If you don't have this you can use
and do these exercises without.
You can try putting an ankle weight on.
Or you can use this.
Foot in a loop.
So I'm gonna do a kickback
that's gonna work into
my hamstring and glute.
So I'm coming into tabletop position.
Kick my leg up.
It's gonna go parallel
against the resistance.
My foot is flexed, my leg is parallel.
Bring that knee into my navel
and I kick straight back.
Into navel, straight back.
Good.
Without the resistance
band, same exercise.
Try an ankle weight.
Straight back.
And straight back, good.
For that one, we're gonna do two sets
of 20 reps on each leg.
And now for our outer and inner thighs.
So our adductors and abductors.
Line up, elbow underneath
shoulder, extend both legs.
Pull up that waist if you
have any shoulder issues,
you can do this laying down.
If not, stay up.
We're gonna work, lift the top leg up.
Outer thigh.
This underneath leg is the working one.
This is the tricky one.
You come underneath it, click that heel,
place it down and lower down.
We do lift and squeeze and down and down.
Lift and squeeze.
You wanna keep those legs parallel.
You're gonna make sure
that your hips are stacked
on top of each other and that your navel's
drawing towards your spine.
And you're just lifting
the leg to hip height.
Parallel and pointed.
Close heels, down and up.
Abduction, adduction.
Whoo hoo hoo.
Good.
And those will also be two
sets of 20 reps on each side.
So those five exercises should take you
about 15 to 20 minutes
in length to do them.
And remember, we don't
wanna speed through it.
We wanna use correct
technique and correct form
because that's the way you see results.
Good luck.